is there like us do you care okay would  you be cool if a guy that makes less  money but he's very he's a hard worker  like he's ambitious  yeah okay so like if he was making like  let's say he just started his own  business but he makes 45 000 a year  would you date him  he wouldn't be able to afford my  engagement ring I'm getting an eight  carat cushion cut vintage engagement  ring if you make forty five thousand  dollars a year it would take what  four years no eight years  I don't know anything about Rings how  much how much is that about two hundred  thousand dollars girl you want a 200 000  are you insane she belongs to the  streets  my ring has to Sparkle from across the  street like you have to answer that  chance you have blind people that's so  superficial that's like so superficial  but